This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1979, the Los Angeles Dodgers signed an unknown picture from Mexico, named Fernando Valenzuela. A couple of years later, in 1981, Valenzuela made his major league debut as a starting picture. That's producer and Angelino, Vivian Lee. Valenzuela went on to have one of the most remarkable seasons in the history of baseball. This obscure player from Sonora, Mexico, became the first player ever to win both the Sia Young Award and Rookie of the Year in the same season. Valenzuela led the Dodgers all the way to the World Series, where they defeated the New York Yankees.
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。1979年，洛杉矶道奇队签下一位来自墨西哥的名不见经传的投手，名叫费尔南多·瓦伦苏埃拉。几年后的1981年，瓦伦苏埃拉作为首发投手迎来了他的大联盟首秀。这是制作人兼洛杉矶人薇薇安·李。随后，瓦伦苏埃拉迎来了棒球史上最耀眼的赛季之一。这位来自墨西哥索诺拉的无名小卒，成为了历史上第一位在同一年包揽赛扬奖和年度最佳新秀的球员。瓦伦苏埃拉一路率领道奇队杀入世界大赛，并在那里击败了纽约扬基队。
For an Ambo Valenzuela, who threw 149 pitches tonight. This season will always be remembered in Los Angeles as the year of Fernandomania. The whole city fell in love with Valenzuela, and in particular, LA's large Mexican-American community. We actually had someone, a real true Mejicano plane baseball for a major league team. This is Edward Santillon, L.A. native and longtime Dodgers fan. And it was in Los Angeles. And as you know, L.A. is so big and it's full of Latinos. We're all struggling to make it in this world and he actually made it and he made
对于今晚投了149球的阿姆博·瓦伦苏埃拉而言。在洛杉矶，这个赛季永远会被铭记为“费尔南多狂热”之年。整座城市都爱上了瓦伦苏埃拉，尤其是洛杉矶庞大的墨西哥裔美国人社区。我们真的有了一个人，一个真正的墨西哥人，在为大联盟球队打棒球。这是爱德华·桑蒂永，土生土长的洛杉矶人兼道奇队的长期球迷。而且它就发生在洛杉矶。如你所知，洛杉矶太大了，到处都是拉丁裔。我们都在这个世界上艰难求生，而他真的成功了，他让
everybody proud. Edward says there was nothing quite like watching a game at Dodger Stadium when Valenzuela was pitching. We would take younger kids that couldn't forward to go to a Dodger game. We would you know get tickets and take them and and have them experience the the cheering and the you know Fernando Mania and Valenzuela and cheering and cheering and screaming for him. So it was, it was a, it was a good time. It was fun. But not everybody in Edwards family wanted to go see Fernando's famous screwball in action. Some of the older folks, especially, were hesitant to make the trek to Dodger Stadium. It was just the younger generation
每个人都感到骄傲。爱德华说，当瓦伦苏埃拉投球时，在道奇体育场看比赛的感觉无与伦比。我们会带那些买不起道奇队门票去看比赛的小孩子们去。你知道的，我们会弄到票，带他们去，让他们体验那种欢呼，你知道的，那种费尔南多狂热，还有瓦伦苏埃拉，为他欢呼，欢呼，尖叫。所以那真的是一段美好的时光，很有趣。但爱德华家并非所有人都想去现场看费尔南多那记著名的诡球大显身手。尤其是有些长辈，对去道奇体育场一路上山显得有些犹豫。只有年轻一代
that would go with us. I don't know, there was still a little bit of animosity towards the Dodgers for what had happened and what transpired up at Chavez-Reveen. Chavez-Reveen was a neighborhood where Edwards' father, Louis grew up, and it used to sit exactly where Dodger Stadium is today. Back in the 1950s, the community at Chavez-Rivine was displaced in a contentious battle to reshape what the city would look like.
才会跟我们一起去。我不知道，对于曾经在查韦斯拉维讷发生和经历过的事，他们对道奇队仍然心存一丝敌意。查韦斯拉维讷是爱德华的父亲路易斯长大的社区，它过去正好位于今天的道奇体育场所在地。早在20世纪50年代，为了重塑城市面貌而引发了一场颇具争议的争夺战，查韦斯拉维讷的社区居民因此流离失所。
Because back then Los Angeles wasn't known as the sprawling world center it is today. In the years since the turn of the century, Los Angeles has grown from a sleepy Pueblo to a vast, seething metropolitan city. It's an up a sleepy po'ueblo to a vast, seeding metropolitan city. It's an up-and-coming city, but it is not really completely there yet. This is Gerald Poder, author of the book, City of Dreams,
因为当时的洛杉矶并不像今天这样是一个庞大的世界中心。自世纪之交以来的这些年里，洛杉矶已经从一个沉睡的小镇发展成为一个广阔、喧嚣的大都会城市。这是一个正在崛起的大都会城市，但它其实还没有完全成型。这是杰拉尔德·波达尔，著有《梦想之城：
Dodger Stadium, and the birth of modern Los Angeles. In the early 20th century, the population of Los Angeles was exploding. People were moving to California for the climate, the jobs, and the cheap real estate. It was a city on the rise, but still something was missing. When Americans were asked to talk about the major cities of the country in the 1950s, obviously they would say New York. They would say Chicago, they would say Boston. They might even say Detroit, but they might not say Los Angeles, and they might even be
道奇体育场与现代洛杉矶的诞生》一书。在20世纪初，洛杉矶的人口呈爆炸式增长。人们为了这里的气候、工作和便宜的房地产而搬到加利福尼亚。这是一座蒸蒸日上的城市，但似乎还缺少点什么。在20世纪50年代，当美国人被问及该国主要城市时，他们显然会说纽约。他们会说芝加哥，他们会说波士顿。他们甚至可能会说底特律，但他们可能不会说洛杉矶，甚至可能
amazed to know how big a city it was. LA didn't have the rows of towering skyscrapers that made New York and Chicago unmistakable, but it was missing something else too, something that was hard to put a finger on. Los Angeles felt more like a collection of neighborhoods than a cohesive city. If you asked in Angelino where they were from, rather than St. Los Angeles, they might say Boyle Heights or Highland Park. If they have any kind of civic identity, it's tied to their neighborhood and not necessarily to their city. So there are very, very few pieces of what I call civic glue in Los Angeles in the 1950s. Very few municipal institutions that everyone in the city can identify with and rally around.
惊讶于它竟然是一座这么大的城市。洛杉矶没有纽约和芝加哥那种鳞次栉比、让人一眼就能认出来的摩天大楼，但它也缺少了别的东西，一种很难具体说清楚的东西。与其说洛杉矶是一个有凝聚力的城市，倒不如说它更像是各个街区的集合。如果你问一个洛杉矶人他们来自哪里，比起说洛杉矶，他们可能会说博伊尔高地或高地公园。如果他们有什么公民认同感的话，那也是跟他们的街区绑定的，而不一定是对整座城市。所以在20世纪50年代的洛杉矶，几乎没有什么我所谓的“城市凝聚剂”。几乎没有什么市政机构是城里每个人都能产生共鸣并团结在它周围的。
And a few city leaders thought if the people of Los Angeles needed something to rally around, let's give them a baseball team. From its inception, professional baseball in the US was played mostly on the East Coast. By 1953, only a couple of teams had ventured west of the Mississippi River, the Cardinals and the Browns, but they only made it as far as St. Louis, which is actually on the Mississippi's with barely counts. But Los Angeles was a west coast city on the rise, and was looking for a way to boost its reputation. And how do you get the reputation?
一些城市领导人认为，如果洛杉矶人民需要某种凝聚人心的东西，那就给他们一支棒球队吧。从诞生之初，美国的职业棒球基本上都是在东海岸进行的。到1953年，只有少数几支球队冒险去了密西西比河以西，即红雀队和布朗队，但他们也只到了圣路易斯，圣路易斯其实就在密西西比河边，几乎算不上。但洛杉矶是一座正在崛起的西海岸城市，一直在寻找提升声誉的方法。怎么才能提升声誉呢？
Well, you get the reputation with big splashy acquisitions like a Major League Baseball team when there is no Major League Baseball on the West Coast. And so LA City leaders began plotting to lure a baseball team out West. One woman named Roslyn Wyman, even campaigned for City Council on the promise to bring a major league team to Los Angeles. And it worked. She was elected to City Council at just 22 years old.
嗯，你得靠大笔引人注目的收购来提升声誉，比如在西海岸还没有职业棒球的时候，引进一支美国职业棒球大联盟球队。于是洛杉矶的城市领导者开始策划将一支棒球队吸引到西部来。一个名叫罗丝琳·怀曼的女性甚至以将大联盟球队带到洛杉矶作为竞选承诺去竞选市议员。这招奏效了。她在年仅22岁时当选为市议员。
And as luck would have it for a Rosy Wyman and other Angelinos desperate for baseball, there was an East Coast team in desperate need of a new stadium. The Brooklyn Daunters. They were a classic baseball team who had been playing at a classic ballpark called Ebott's Field. And these days, New Yorkers loved getting nostalgic about Quaint, little Ebott's Field
对于罗丝·怀曼以及其他渴望棒球的洛杉矶人来说，幸运的是，东海岸有一支极其渴望新球场的球队。布鲁克林道奇队。他们是一支传统的棒球队，一直在一个名叫埃贝茨球场的经典球场打比赛。如今，纽约人很喜欢怀念那个位于布鲁克林市中心、
right in the heart of Brooklyn. But those who are nostalgic about seeing a game at Ebott's Field probably never actually were there. The Ebott's Field had a lot of problems. There were columns obstructing the view of the field, steep climbs to the upper deck, barely any parking or freeway access, and the building itself was falling apart. The team owner, Walter O'Malley, wanted to build his own modern, well-designed stadium in
古朴而小巧的埃贝茨球场。但那些怀念在埃贝茨球场看比赛的人可能根本就没去过那里。埃贝茨球场有很多问题。有遮挡视线的柱子，通往上层看台的陡峭阶梯，几乎没有停车位或高速公路出入口，而且建筑本身也在分崩离析。球队老板沃尔特·奥马利想在布鲁克林建造他自己的现代化、设计精良的球场。
Brooklyn. He even went so far as to hire Buckminster Fuller to draft plans for a dome to go over the top of the field that would turn the stadium into an all-weather facility. You don't usually think of baseball team owners as being friends with futurist architects, but in this case, that was what was going on. O'Malley fought for years first to dream of a privately owned stadium, but there was one very powerful bureaucrat standing in the way. New York's infamous master builder, Robert Moses.
他甚至雇用了巴克明斯特·富勒来为球场上方起草一个穹顶的设计方案，这将把球场变成一个全天候设施。你通常不会把棒球俱乐部老板和未来主义建筑师联系在一起，但在这种情况下，事情就是这样发展的。奥马利抗争了多年，首先是为了实现拥有一个私人球场的美梦，但有一个极其强大的官僚挡在了他的去路。纽约声名狼藉的“造城大师”罗伯特·摩西。
It just so happened that Robert Moses not only didn't like spectator sports, he thought that spectator sports were a total waste of time and for what he called the Rooms. And without Moses' support, a new Dodger stadium in Brooklyn was basically impossible. And O'Malley said, well, one, I'm a Brooklynite and I want the park to be in Brooklyn.
碰巧的是，罗伯特·摩西不仅不喜欢观赏性体育运动，他还认为观赏性体育运动完全是在浪费时间，是给那些他所谓的小民百姓准备的。没有摩西的支持，在布鲁克林建造一座新的道奇体育场基本上是不可能的。奥马利说，好吧，第一，我是布鲁克林人，我希望球场建在布鲁克林。
If it's in Queens, it might as well be 10,000 miles away. O'Malley figured if he couldn't get his dream stadium in Brooklyn, he might as well move the Dodgers all the way out to California. Ross Wyman and the City Council invited O'Malley out to Los Angeles for a visit. He had, by my estimation, had spent a total of 10 days in his entire life in Los Angeles. He doesn't really know where he wants to build a stadium.
如果它在皇后区，那它干脆离这儿有一万英里远得了。奥马利心想，如果他在布鲁克林建不成梦想中的球场，那他索性就把道奇队整个搬到加利福尼亚去。罗斯·怀曼和市议会邀请奥马利到洛杉矶参观。据我估计，他一生中总共在洛杉矶待了10天。他其实并不知道自己想在哪里建球场。
He hasn't made the deal yet to come to Los Angeles, but he's scouting it out. So O'Malley decided to take a helicopter ride across the city to get a feel for the area. And he saw something that caught his eye, what looked like an empty piece of land, just a few miles from downtown. This hilly area was called Chavez-Rivine.
他还没敲定来洛杉矶的交易，但他正在实地考察。于是奥马利决定坐直升机飞越这座城市，来感受一下这个地区。他看到了吸引他眼球的东西，一块看起来空旷的土地，距离市中心只有几英里。这个丘陵地带被称为查韦斯拉维讷。
The thing that he sees is all the vacant land around Chavez-Rivine, but it was surrounded by the freeways. This is Mark Langel, the official historian for the LA Dodgers. He says that the freeways made the site appealing because it meant that fans would have easy access to the stadium. The terrain was really hilly, and O'Malley knew he would need to do a huge amount of work to flatten out the land, but it was all worth it because of the highway access. He even estimated the amount of land that would have to be moved.
他看到的是查韦斯拉维讷周围所有的空地，但它被高速公路环绕着。这是洛杉矶道奇队的官方历史学家马克·兰格尔。他说，高速公路使这个选址很有吸引力，因为这意味着球迷可以非常方便地前往球场。这里的地形非常多山，奥马利知道他需要做大量的平整土地工作，但为了高速公路的便利，这一切都是值得的。他甚至估算了需要移动的土地数量。
That didn't bother him because it's easy to move that land, but it's hard to build three or four different freeways. But O'Malley probably didn't realize that the plot of land that he had his eye on wasn't completely empty. There were a few families living in Chavez-Rovine that had been there a long time, and if the Dodgers were going to build a stadium there, they'd have to kick those people out. And it wouldn't be the first time that the people of Chavez-Rovine had been forced to leave their home.
这并没有困扰他，因为移动那些土地很容易，但要修建三四条不同的高速公路却很难。但奥马利可能没有意识到，他看中的这片土地并非完全空无一人。查韦斯拉维讷住着几户人家，他们已经在那里住了很长时间，如果道奇队要在那儿建一座体育场，他们就必须把这些人赶走。而且这也不是查韦斯拉维讷的人民第一次被迫离开家园了。
O'Malley thought he saw a vast empty stretch of land from the helicopter, but what he was really seeing were the last legs of a community that had existed there since the early 1900s. And for a long time, it was a neighborhood full of life. It was very colorful because the ladies had colorful birds, canaries were big. I mean, that's what would wake us up, canaries in the morning singing. And it was just a very colorful community. This is Carol Hawkes. Yes, my name is Carol Hawkes, and it's spelled J-A-C-Q-E-S.
奥马利以为他从直升机上看到的是一片广阔的空地，但他真正看到的是一个自20世纪初以来就存在那里的社区的最后余晖。而且很长一段时间里，那是一个充满生气的社区。它非常多姿多彩，因为太太们养了五颜六色的鸟，金丝雀很受欢迎。我的意思是，那就是每天早晨唤醒我们的声音，金丝雀在晨光中歌唱。那真是一个非常多彩的社区。这是卡罗尔·霍克斯。是的，我的名字叫卡罗尔·霍克斯，拼写是J-A-C-Q-E-S。
Carol is 76 years old now and still lives in Los Angeles. And as a little girl, she grew up in Chavez-Reveen. I know you're pretty young when you left. So as much as you could remember, I'll... Oh, I can remember a lot. Okay. Carol was only 9 or 10 years old when her family left Chavez-Reveen. But her memories are crystal clear.
卡罗尔现在76岁了，仍然住在洛杉矶。作为一个小女孩，她是在查韦斯拉维讷长大的。我知道你离开的时候挺小的。所以你能记住多少，我……噢，我能记住很多。好的。卡罗尔的家人离开查韦斯拉维讷时只有9到10岁。但她的记忆依然清晰如水晶。
It was very rural, so we could always see the trees. And at that time, when I was growing up anyway, at this time of year, there'd always be like a fog when you woke up. Chavez-Rivine was like a small town within the city, and it was home to mostly Mexican and Mexican-American families. It was made up of three different neighborhoods called Palo Verde, La Loma, and Bishop. Some roads were paved, but most weren't. A lot of homes had electricity, but some didn't.
那里非常乡村化，所以我们总能看到树木。那时，无论如何在我成长的时候，每到每年的这个时候，当你醒来时总会有雾。查韦斯拉维讷就像是城市里的小镇，主要是墨西哥和墨西哥裔美国人家庭的家园。它由三个不同的社区组成，分别叫帕洛韦尔德、拉洛马和毕肖普。有些道路是铺面路，但大多数不是。许多房屋通了电，但有些没有。
In its own way, though, it was still a flourishing, closely knit community. We were like any other neighborhood. We had some people that were doing very well. There were some families that were very poor. There were some families that were not so nice. There were some families that were very poor. There were some families that were not so nice. There were some families that were very religious, but they were all still friends and everybody knew each other. Chavez Reveen was located just a few miles from downtown Los Angeles, but it felt like a world apart.
不过，用它自己的方式来说，它仍然是一个蓬勃发展、紧密团结的社区。我们就像其他任何社区一样。我们有一些过得很好的人。有些家庭非常穷。有些家庭不是很好。有些家庭非常穷。有些家庭不是很好。有些家庭非常虔诚，但大家依然都是朋友，每个人都互相认识。查韦斯拉维讷距离洛杉矶市中心只有几英里，但感觉却像是一个完全不同的世界。
It was this isolated pocket within the city. It had its own schools, churches, stores, a barbershop. The residents had everything they needed without ever having to leave the neighborhood. But a lot of the reason why they were so independent was because they had to be. 60% of the people, the Mexican, Mexican-American people that were living in Chavez-Ravine area owned their own home. And the reason is because that was the only place in the city we could live because of the covenants. Covenants were racial restrictions that limited where people of color could actually purchase property. From the 1910s through the 1940s, Chavez-Ravine was one of the few
它是城市里一个孤立的角落。它有自己的学校、教堂、商店、理发店。居民们拥有他们需要的一切，甚至不需要离开社区。但他们之所以如此独立，很大程度上是因为他们不得不这样。查韦斯拉维讷地区60%的人口，即墨西哥和墨西哥裔美国人，都拥有自己的房屋。原因在于，由于契约限制，那是城里我们唯一能住的地方。契约是对有色人种实际购买房产的地点进行限制的种族限制条款。从20世纪10年代到40年代，查韦斯拉维讷是洛杉矶少数几个
places in Los Angeles that non-white people could actually own a home. The first threat to this community was not actually the baseball stadium. It came years before in the form of a new housing project. In 1949, the federal government passed the National Housing Act, which allocated funds to cities all over the country in order to build new low-income housing for people in need. Los Angeles itself was going to be home to 10,000 of these new public housing units. This was part of an effort to providing affordable, sanitary living conditions
非白人可以真正拥有房产的地方之一。这个社区面临的第一个威胁其实并不是棒球场。它几年前就以一项新住房计划的形式出现了。1949年，联邦政府通过了《国家住房法》，向全国各地的城市拨款，以便为有需要的人建造新的低收入住房。洛杉矶本身将迎来10,000套这样的新公共住房单元。这是为无力自行解决住房问题的人
for people who were not able to provide that for themselves. This is Eric Abila, professor of history in Chicano Studies at UCLA. He says that the city selected Chavez-Rivin to be the site for 3600 new units because the city housing authority, or CHA, had determined it was a slum. The CHA claimed that it was infested with rats, homes lacked electricity and toilets, and it was actually in their best interests that the community be replaced with new modern housing.
提供负担得起的、卫生的居住条件的一部分努力。这是埃里克·阿维拉，加州大学洛杉矶分校奇卡诺人研究的历史学教授。他说，市政府之所以选择查韦斯拉维讷作为3600套新住房的选址，是因为市房屋管理局（简称CHA）认定那里是个贫民窟。CHA声称那里鼠患成灾，房屋缺乏电力和厕所，而用新的现代化住宅取代这个社区实际上最符合他们的最大利益。
From an urban planning perspective, or from the perspective of city hall, a poor community like the Chavez-Rivine fit their idea of what Aslam was at the time. But if you talk to the people who remembered what it was like to live in the Chavez-Rivine, they didn't think of their neighborhood as Aslam. We had fleshing toilets everywhere that I went. And I went into a lot of houses and when I had to go to the bathroom, we had fleshing toilets everywhere that I went. And I went into a lot of houses and when I had to go to the bathroom, we had fleshing toilets. We had some lights, not a lot, because we could still see all the stars at night without any problem whatsoever.
从城市规划的角度来看，或者从市政厅的角度来看，像查韦斯拉维讷这样的贫民社区符合他们当时对贫民窟的看法。但如果你和那些还记得在查韦斯拉维讷生活是什么样的人谈谈，他们并不认为自己的社区是贫民窟。我去的每个地方都有冲水马桶。我去过很多房子，当我要上厕所时，我们去的每个地方都有冲水马桶。我去过很多房子，当我要上厕所时，我们都有冲水马桶。我们有一些灯，不多，因为我们晚上在没有任何问题的情况下仍然能看到所有的星星。
We had a lot of things that would not mark us as slums. But because Chavez-Rivine was officially designated a slum, the city housing authority was able to use eminent domain to clear the land for the housing project. Property owning residents were offered payment for their homes, which was far below market value. And it's actually debatable whether you could even call it an offer. Carol remembers when a man named Frank Wilkinson, who was in charge of the housing project, came to the house.
我们有很多东西不会让我们被称为贫民窟。但由于查韦斯拉维讷被官方指定为贫民窟，市房屋管理局得以使用征用权来为住房项目腾出土地。拥有房产的居民得到了远低于市场价的房屋赔偿。而且这是否能被称为“报价”其实都值得商榷。卡罗尔记得当一个名叫弗兰克·威尔金森的负责人（他负责这个住房项目）来到家里时的情况。
I remember when that actual knock on the door came and he wasn't that congingue, you know, he wasn't really that nice, but... What was he there to tell you when he knocked on the door? He was there to tell us that we had no no choice. That was made very clear that there was no choice that we all had to move. Almost everyone in Chavez-Rovine ended up selling their homes and then moving to different parts of the city. By 1948, the restrictive covenants that prevented families of color from moving into other areas were ruled unconstitutional, and a lot of these former residents became the first Mexican and Mexican-American families in these new neighborhoods.
我记得当真正敲门声响起时，他并不是那么随和，你知道的，他其实没那么好……他敲门的时候是来对你说了什么？他是来告诉我们，我们别无选择。这一点说得很清楚，我们没有选择，我们都必须搬走。查韦斯拉维讷的几乎所有人都最终卖掉了他们的房子，然后搬到了城市的其他地方。到1948年，阻止有色人种家庭搬到其他地区的限制性契约被裁定违宪，许多这些前居民成为了这些新街区的第一批墨西哥和墨西哥裔美国人家庭。
We moved into what was a completely white community at the time, but what was going on for me when I moved there, there was a lot of white flag going on. I mean, people like me, they were leaving, we're leaving because of people like me coming in. Some residents were told that they would be first in line to move into the new public housing community at Chavez-Rovine, but those hopes were short-lived. In 1953, a new Los Angeles mayor named Norris Polson took office with an ideological objection to the project. He branded public housing as a communist plot or a socialist conspiracy. Pulson thought that subsidized housing
我们搬进了一个当时完全是白人的社区，但当我搬到那里时，发生的事情是，有很多白人群体在搬离。我的意思是，像我这样的人，他们在离开，我们离开是因为像我这样的人搬进来了。一些居民被告知，他们将优先搬进查韦斯拉维讷的新公共住房社区，但这些希望并没有维持多久。1953年，一位名叫诺里斯·波尔森的新洛杉矶市长上任，他对该项目抱有意识形态上的反对意见。他将公共住房打上共产主义阴谋或社会主义阴谋的烙印。波尔森认为对穷人的补贴住房
for the poor sounded like communist sense and he made sure that the housing project was dead in the water. The people of Chavez-Ravine have been displaced for no reason. Except for a small number of people who refused to leave their homes, the community of Chavez-Rivine was basically gone. We would go there, you know, it's like, oh, look, there's the house or this or that,
听起来像是共产主义的疯话，他确保了这个住房项目彻底胎死腹中。查韦斯拉维讷的人民莫名其妙地流离失所。除了极少数拒绝离开家园的人之外，查韦斯拉维讷社区基本上已经不复存在了。我们会去那里，你知道的，就像是，噢，看，那是房子或者这个那个，
oh, they took all the flowers out of this yard and we would just go back and visit, but it was a ghost town, except for a handful of people. All the stores were gone, the church was gone, they knocked down the school. The city ended up buying the land from the Federal Housing Authority and left it undeveloped for years while it figured out how to put the property to public use. And that's where the Dodgers come back into the picture. Walter O'Malley was convinced that Chavez-Rovine was the perfect place to build his perfect stadium.
噢，他们把这个院子里的所有花都拔掉了，我们就会回去看看，但除了少数几个人之外，那里成了一座鬼城。所有的商店都没了，教堂没了，他们推倒了学校。市政府最终从联邦住房管理局手中买下了这片土地，并在弄清楚如何将这块土地用于公共用途之前，将其闲置了多年。道奇队就在这里重新回到了人们的视线中。沃尔特·奥马利坚信查韦斯拉维讷是建造他完美球场的绝佳地点。
And at first it looked like it might be smooth sailing. The City Council approved the deal to give the land to the Dodgers. But as it turned out, a lot of people were opposed to the Dodger deal for reasons that had nothing to do with Chava's ravine. They didn't want the city subsidizing a private business, even if that business was baseball. In fact, the opposition was so intense that the city decided to put the deal up for a referendum. This meant that the following year, the contract would be placed on a ballot, and the citizens of LA would get the chance to vote on the new stadium.
起初，事情看起来似乎一帆风顺。市议会批准了将土地交给道奇队的协议。但事实证明，许多人反对道奇队的协议，原因与查韦斯拉维讷毫无关系。他们不希望城市补贴一个私营企业，即使那家企业是棒球。事实上，反对的声音如此强烈，以至于市政府决定将这项协议提交全民公投。这意味着第二年，这份合同将被列入选票，洛杉矶市民将有机会对新球场进行投票。
And in the end, voters did come out in the Dodgers favor, but just barely. But there was still the issue of the handful of remaining holdouts living in Chavez-Rovine. Even though the Federal Housing Authority had tried to clear the land, there were a small number of families refused to give up their homes. Those who remained did so in protest. There were only about 20 families left after the Federal Housing Authority tried to clear the land, and they needed to be evicted in order to start construction.
最后，选民确实投了赞成道奇队的票，但只是险胜。但仍然存在少数坚守阵地、住在查韦斯拉维讷的钉子户的问题。尽管联邦住房管理局曾试图清理这片土地，但仍有少数家庭拒绝放弃他们的家园。留下的人以这种方式进行抗议。在联邦住房管理局试图清理土地后，只剩下大约20户人家，为了开始施工，必须将他们驱逐。
These residents had watched their community disappear around them, while the city referred to them as squatters. That was their land, that was their property. I guess you could say that they were squatting, but from their perspective, they had owned that land for several generations. That's not squatting. On May 9, 1959, their time had run out. The city of Los Angeles sent sheriffs deputies to Chavez-Rovín to remove anyone who had
这些居民眼睁睁看着他们的社区在周围消失，而市政府却把他们称为“占地者”。那是他们的土地，那是他们的财产。我想你可以说他们占用了土地，但从他们的角度来看，他们已经拥有这片土地好几代人了。那不叫占用。1959年5月9日，他们的时间到了。洛杉矶市派遣治安官副手前往查韦斯拉维讷，驱逐任何
refused to leave. What followed was a horrific scene of a family called the Arachegas being dragged out of their house. Their daughter, a woman named Aurora Vargas, was physically lifted and carried out of the doorway of her own home. This was captured on camera by reporters. We couldn't find any audio recordings, but it was broadcast all over the country. There are these scenes that are indelibly impressed into the living memory of Los Angeles, of a mother and her children being forcefully evicted from their homes. A grandmother carried out in her rocking chair
拒绝离开的人。随之而来的是可怕的一幕：一个叫阿拉切加的家庭被拖出了他们的房子。他们的女儿，一个叫奥罗拉·瓦尔加斯的女性，被强行抬起并搬出了她自己家的门口。这一幕被记者用镜头捕捉了下来。我们找不到任何音频记录，但它在全国各地进行了广播。这些画面深深印入了洛杉矶的活记忆中，一位母亲和她的孩子们被强行驱逐出家园。一位祖母坐在她的摇椅里被抬出
from their home. Dogs barking, chickens flying everywhere. Children crying, it was a complete melee. When I saw Aurora of Argus on television being forcefully taken out of her house, I saw the house being knocked down. That was really true. That was the point where I hated the Dodgers. Because in my head, that's all I could see is this wonderful kind of nirvana place that I grew up in. I was sad to have left that, of course, but I saw them knocking down and doing what they did live on TV. I was, I don't know, 15, but it was pretty traumatic for me. The evictions dredged up memories not just of a failed housing project years earlier,
家门。狗在叫，鸡到处飞。孩子们在哭喊，现场一片混乱。当我在电视上看到奥罗拉·瓦尔加斯被强行带出她的房子时，我看到房子被推倒了。那是真的。那就是我恨道奇队的那一刻。因为在我的脑海里，我能看到的只有我生于长斯的那个美妙如涅槃般的乐园。我当然很难过离开那里，但我看到他们在电视上直播推倒房屋并做着他们所做的事。我当时，我不知道，15岁，但这对我来说非常具有创伤性。这些驱逐勾起的不仅是几年前失败的住房项目的美好回忆，
but of an entire history of racial discrimination that Latino and Chicano Americans had been experiencing in Los Angeles for decades. And if you know anything about Mexican-American history, it is a history of conquest, it is a history of displacement, and it is a history most of all of land dispossession. So this scene really hit a nerve with a community that had long suffered the indignity, the pain, the inconvenience of displacement
而是拉丁裔和奇卡诺美国人几十年来在洛杉矶经历的整部种族歧视历史。如果你对墨西哥裔美国人的历史有所了解，那是一部征服的历史，是一部流离失所的历史，最重要的是，这是一部土地剥夺的历史。因此，这一幕确实触动了一个长期以来饱受屈辱、痛苦、流离失所的不便，尤其是土地剥夺之痛的社区的神经。
and land dispossession in particular. It just hit a nerve. What happened at Chavez or Vene will always be part of the team's legacy, but it wouldn't be fair to blame all that pain on the Dodgers. The Dodgers got blamed for this, although it wasn't the Dodgers who removed these families, it was the city who removed these families. Here's Gerald Poetaregan. I think it is unfair to say that the Dodgers removed these families. The chain of events is a little different.
它就是触动了那根神经。发生在查韦斯拉维讷的事情将永远是这支球队历史的一部分，但把所有的痛苦都归咎于道奇队是不公平的。道奇队为此背了黑锅，尽管赶走这些家庭的不是道奇队，而是市政府。这是杰拉尔德·波达尔。我认为把赶走这些家庭归咎于道奇队是不公平的。事件的发展链条有点不同。
This history is complicated. It's hard to sum up all the forces and events that led to the destruction of Chavez-Rovine, but the stadium has become a monument, a physical reminder of the community that was displaced from the land on which it sits. Today, Dodger Stadium is the third oldest ballpark in baseball, and you have to admit, it's a beautiful stadium. It's symmetrical with elegant lines, amazing views of the city, and somehow even a bad seat is still a pretty good seat. In some ways, the ballpark did exactly what those politicians back in the 1950s wanted it to do. The Dodgers are a civic institution, beloved by people throughout the city. The Dodgers are even known for having one of the most diverse fan bases in baseball,
这段历史很复杂。很难概括导致查韦斯拉维讷毁灭的所有力量和事件，但这座体育场已经成为了一座纪念碑，一个对坐落于此的土地上流离失所的社区的实体提醒。如今，道奇体育场是棒球场中第三古老的球场，你不得不承认，它是一座美丽的球场。它对称且线条优雅，拥有迷人的城市景观，不知何故，即使是糟糕的座位也依然是个相当不错的座位。在某种程度上，这座球场完全做到了20世纪50年代那些政客们希望它做到的事情。道奇队是一个受到全城人民喜爱的城市机构。道奇队甚至以拥有棒球界最多元化的球迷群体之一而闻名，
thanks in large part to LA's Latino community. I would have to say that LA's Mexican-American community is of two minds on this issue. I think many Mexican-Americans see the Chavez-Rivine as part of a larger story of discrimination and displacement in Southern California. On the other hand, Mexican-Americans are among the Dodgers biggest fans, and that was especially true in the early 1980s with the arrival of Fernando Valenzuela. And Fernando Mania isn't the only reason why. The Dodgers have tried to appeal to the LA Latino community from the very beginning with broadcasters like Jaime Horene,
这很大程度上要归功于洛杉矶的拉丁裔社区。我不得不说，洛杉矶的墨西哥裔美国人社区在这个问题上有两种看法。我认为许多墨西哥裔美国人将查韦斯拉维讷视为南加州歧视和流离失所更大故事的一部分。另一方面，墨西哥裔美国人是道奇队最忠实的球迷之一，在20世纪80年代初费尔南多·瓦伦苏埃拉到来时尤其如此。而且“费尔南多狂热”并不是唯一的理由。道奇队从一开始就试图吸引洛杉矶的拉丁裔社区，比如棒球评论员海梅·霍林，
who's been calling games for the team in Spanish for almost as long as the Dodgers have been in LA. La protaceba, seba, seba, y despita la comundezón. Se fue de cuadráncula. Edward Santeon's father, Lewis, was one of the many who refused to see games at Dodger Stadium. He didn't blame the team for what happened to his community, but the stadium would always be a reminder of the home he used to have. His claim to fame is that he was born where third base is up and his umbilical cord back then would be buried wherever you know you were born. So he
他用西班牙语为这支球队解说比赛的时间几乎和道奇队在洛杉矶的时间一样长。爱德华·桑蒂永的父亲路易斯是众多拒绝去道奇体育场看比赛的人之一。他并没有因为自己社区发生的事而责怪球队，但这座体育场永远会提醒他曾经的家。他引以为豪的是，他出生在三垒所在的地方，当时你的脐带会被埋在你出生的地方。所以他
claims that third base that every time somebody hits a triple or a home run he would get a pain in his stomach because that's where his umbilical cord is buried at. On the third Saturday of July, former residents of Chavez ravine get together for an annual reunion picnic in Elision Park. Edwards' father, Louis, started the tradition years ago and named the group Los Desedados, meaning be uprooted. And they don't get together out of anger.
声称三垒那里——每次有人打出三垒安打或本垒打，他的肚子就会痛，因为他的脐带就埋在那里。每年七月的第三个星期六，查韦斯拉维讷的前居民们会聚在一起，在埃利森公园举行一年一度的聚会野餐。爱德华的父亲路易斯多年前发起了这个传统，并将这个群体命名为“Los Desarraigados”，意为“被根除的人”。他们聚在一起并不是出于愤怒。
They're not there to protest the Dodgers. It's just a bunch of friends and family who want to tell stories and celebrate the neighborhood that they shared beneath the ballpark. What the hell is a dodger anyway? Vivian will be back to tell us after this. So I'm back in the studio with Vivian Lee, and we're going to talk a little bit more about the dodgers, and namely, where the name, the Dodgers, comes from. So this is kind of embarrassing. I am from Southern California. I moved here from LA. So the Dodgers
他们不是去抗议道奇队的。这只是一群朋友和家人，想要讲述故事并庆祝他们在球场下共同拥有的街区。到底什么是道奇队（Dodger）？薇薇安稍后会回来告诉我们。我又回到了演播室和薇薇安·李一起，我们要多聊聊道奇队，也就是“道奇”这个名字的由来。这有点尴尬。我来自南加州。我从洛杉矶搬到这里的。所以道奇队
have essentially been my team my entire life. And I didn't realize until I started working on this story that I had no idea what the hell a Dodger is. Like, you've never wondered or you've never been told or anything. I've never thought about it. I'd never realized that that's an action. And so I just, you know, just, I guess I didn't really think of it either. So what is a Dodger and what exactly are they dodging? So the name actually comes from where the team originally started out, which is Brooklyn, where they were known as the Brooklyn trolley Dodgers. So that makes sense because Brooklyn used to have a lot of trolleys that were on the street and you had a Dodgers. Yes, exactly. The team actually
基本上伴随了我一整个人生。直到我开始做这个报道之前，我才意识到我根本不知道“道奇”（Dodger）到底是个什么鬼。就像，你从来没有想过，或者从来没人告诉你之类的。我从来没想过。我从来没意识到这是一个动作。所以我就，你知道的，我猜我也没怎么想过。那到底什么是道奇，他们到底在“道奇”（闪躲）什么？这个名字实际上来自于球队最初发迹的地方，也就是布鲁克林，当时他们被称为布鲁克林电车躲闪者（trolley Dodgers）。所以这说得通，因为布鲁克林过去有很多在街上行驶的电车，你得躲开它们。是的，没错。这支球队实际上
went by a few nicknames before this. They officially started as the Atlantis. And then they were nicknamed the Brooklyn bridegrooms for a while. And this was so weird. It's because like six or seven of the team members happened to get married around the same time that year. And the nickname just stuck. Wow. A lot of like major league teams in the early days, they went by nicknames instead of their official name. So it kind of, it changed a lot over time. Oh, that's interesting. Yeah, but back in the mid 1890s, that's when they first started being referred to as the Charlie Dodgers,
在此之前用过几个昵称。他们最初正式以亚特兰蒂斯队起家。然后他们有一段时间被称为布鲁克林新郎队。这太奇怪了。那是因为那一年球队里大约有六七个成员恰好在同一时间左右结婚了。这个昵称就这么叫开了。哇。早期的大联盟球队有很多都用绰号而不是正式名称。所以它随着时间的推移变化挺大的。噢，真有趣。是的，但在19世纪90年代中期，也就是他们开始被称为“电车躲闪者”的时候，
thanks to a man named General Henry Slocum. Okay, so that name sounds vaguely from others, but please remind me. Yeah, so if you've ever heard of the PS General Slocum disaster, that ship was named after this guy. Okay. He was a Civil War general from Atlanta and then moved to New York after the war and served in Congress.
多亏了一个名叫亨利·斯洛库姆将军的人。好吧，这个名字听起来有点耳熟，但请提醒我。是的，如果你听说过“斯洛库姆将军号”PS灾难，那艘船就是以这个人命名的。好的。他是来自亚特兰大的一位内战将军，战后搬到纽约并在国会供职。
And in 1891, General Slokum kind of made it his mission to modernize transportation and bring electric street cars to Brooklyn. And at first the city denied this request because they thought this sounds dangerous. But in 1892, Brooklyn's trolley ordinance passed, which approved the conversion from horse drawn to electric trawlies. And was it as dangerous as people thought it might be? 100% because, you know, before that horse drawn trawlies were the standards. So trolley rails were laid out all over the place, like in Brooklyn and Manhattan and Brooklyn streets were basically already a maze of these trolley
1891年，斯洛库姆将军把实现交通现代化和将有轨电车引入布鲁克林当作了自己的使命。起初，市政府拒绝了这个请求，因为他们觉得这听起来很危险。但在1892年，布鲁克林的电车条例通过了，批准将马拉电车改造为电动电车。它真的像人们想象的那样危险吗？百分之百，因为，你知道的，在此之前马拉电车是标准配置。所以电车轨道到处都是，比如在布鲁克林和曼哈顿，布鲁克林街头基本上已经成了这些电车轨道的迷宫。
rails. And at first it seemed like a good idea because you could go faster and you could be, you know, much more efficient and cleaner because there's no horses and no. But, you know, if you compound that with the fact that there's pedestrians all over the streets and you're suddenly changing this technology that people have to adapt to very quickly. It just became a disaster. It's funny, because when I hear the name Charlie Dodgers, it actually sounds kind of cute and quaint, but this is really like,
起初这似乎是个好主意，因为你可以走得更快，你可以，你知道的，效率更高，而且更干净，因为没有马，没有。但是，你知道的，再加上街上到处都是行人的事实，你突然改变了这种人们不得不非常迅速适应的技术。这简直成了一场灾难。这很有趣，因为当我听到“电车躲闪者”这个名字时，它其实听起来挺可爱和古朴的，但实际上，街道对人们来说突然变得致命了，因为这些巨大的电车在这些轨道上开得非常非常快。是的，是的，是的。所以这是汽车文化之前的事。所以人们只是不习惯在过马路之前左右看看。而马拉电车并不是很危险，
the streets were deadly for people, all of a sudden, because these giant cars were going very, very fast on these rails. Yes, yeah, yeah. So this is pre-automobile culture. So people just weren't used to looking both ways before or crossing the street. And horse-drawn trawlies were not very dangerous
因为你大概可以迈着轻快的步伐跟它并肩走，还能保持相同的速度。对吧。所以电动电车开得快得多，它让人猝不及防，因此这就需要进行“电车躲闪”。是的。而且这些电车的速度是其他电车的整整三倍。
because you could probably briskly power walk next to one and still go the same speed. Right. So the electric cars are going a lot faster and it was just catching people off guard and so it required trawly dodging. Yes. And these trawlers were going three times faster as, you know, other trawlies.
危险到在1892年，也就是它们被引入的第一年，就发生了5起死亡事故。第二年，有51人死亡。到1895年，电车已经夺去了107人的生命，并造成至少400人受伤。所以人们不得不字面意义上跳开去躲避这些，基本上就像是杀戮机器一样的东西。对吧。而且有一些政治漫画
And it was so dangerous that in 1892, the first year that they're introduced, there's five deaths. The next year, there are 51 deaths. And by 1895, trawlies had already killed 107 people and injured at least 400 other people. So people are literally having to jump out of the way of these, like basically like death machines. Right. And there's these political cartoons
来自那个时期的漫画简直有点吓人。好吧，我正在看一张，你刚刚在这里给我看了一张。这是在缆车尾迹中。街上有残缺不整的尸体，就像被碾过一样。是的，有很多人在哭泣。是的，很黑暗。确实如此。噢，天哪。那是什么促使你用这个来给棒球队命名呢？嗯，奇怪的是，这其实算是一种赞美。
from around that time and they're just kind of horrifying. Okay, so I'm looking at one, you just showed me one here. It's this in the wake of a cable car. And it has just maimed bodies on the street like have run over Yeah, there's like many suits crying. Yeah, it's dark. It really is. Oh my god So what would possess you to name a baseball team after this? Well the weird thing is it was kind of a compliment
所以你只能在像纽约或芝加哥这样高度城市化的地区找到电动电车。所以不得不积极地跳开躲避，这让你成为了一个现代大都市人的标志。也是一个现代大都市的标志。所以这对城市是好事，对个人也是好事。我明白了，我明白了。那么电车是在什么时候离开布鲁克林的呢？
So you only found electric trolleys in highly urbanized areas like New York or Chicago So having to actively jump out of the way We only found electric trolleys in highly urbanized areas like New York or Chicago. So having to actively jump out of the way, it made you, it was the mark of like a modern cosmopolitan person. And also a modern cosmopolitan city. So it was good on the city, it was good on the person. I get it, I get it. So at what point did the trolleys be brokler?
它们在大正年代左右开始消失，大约也就是汽车文化开始兴起的时候。所以我们基本上迎来了下一代事物。但这个名字留了下来，“电车躲闪者”留了下来。最终，名字被简化为布鲁克林道奇队。然后在1957年搬迁时最终成为了洛杉矶道奇队。当他们在1957年搬迁时，红色电车还在
So they started disappearing around the 1920s, which is around the time that car culture started popping up. So we're on the next thing, basically. But the name stuck, the Trolley Dodgers stuck. And eventually, they got shortened to the Brooklyn Dodgers. And then eventually became the Los Angeles Dodgers when they moved in 1957. And when they moved in 1957, was the red car still going
洛杉矶运行吗？洛杉矶还有电车剩下吗？是的，好的。是的，大约还有四年。好吧。他们本可以——他们本可以躲开可能一辆车、一辆红色电车。噢，太搞笑了。是的，酷。好吧。谢谢。本周的《99%隐形》由薇薇安·李制作，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·尤素夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括埃弗里·特劳夫曼、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰尼·霍尔、
on Los Angeles? Were there any trolleys left in Los Angeles? Yes, okay. Yes, there were for about four years Okay, they could have they could have dodged like probably one car one one red car Oh, it's funny. Yeah cool. All right. Thanks. Thank you 99% invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lee, Mix and Tech Production by Shereef Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Trouffleman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald Delaney Hall,
塔伦·马扎、索菲亚·克拉茨克以及我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢卡罗尔·霍克斯和普莉希拉·莱瓦，他们一直致力于一项口述历史和保护项目，记录查韦斯拉维讷前居民的故事。该项目名为《查韦斯拉维讷：未完成的故事》。了解更多信息请访问 chavez-Rovine-la.com。我们是旧金山 91.7 K-A-L-W 的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街。99%隐形是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个充满独立精神的集体，
Taren Mazza, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Carol Hawkes and Priscilla Leyva, they've been working on an oral history and preservation project documenting the stories of the former residents of Chavez-Rovine. It's called Chavez-Rovine, an unfinished story. Find out more at chavez-Rovine-la.com. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
汇集了所有播客中最具创新性的节目。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或@节目 @99PI Ork。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也都有账号。但如果你想看查韦斯拉维讷的前后对比照片，请访问 99pi.org。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want before and after pictures of Chavez ReRovine, look no further than 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客界最具创新性的节目之一。请访问 radiotopia.fm 查找所有节目。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars 以及本节目 @99PI Ork。我们在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也都有账号。但如果您想看查韦斯·雷罗维内（Chavez ReRovine）改造前后的照片，请访问 99pi.org。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。